ammonia is an example of a weak base and
hydrochloric acid is an example of a
strong acid and if we're doing a weak
base strong acid titration that means
that ammonia is the analyte the
substance we're analyzing and we're
titrating ammonia with hydrochloric acid
and therefore hydrochloric acid is the
titrant
and when ammonia reacts with
hydrochloric acid the product is an
aqueous solution of ammonium chloride
for our complete or overall ionic
equation since ammonia is a weak base we
show it as nh3 in our complete ionic
equation however since hydrochloric acid
is a strong acid that ionizes 100
percent we show it as breaking up into
its ions so h plus and cl minus
ammonium chloride is a soluble salt
therefore we would show ammonium
chloride in aqueous solution as ammonium
cations and chloride anions to write the
net ionic equation we leave out
spectator ions and since we have
chloride anions on the left side and on
the right side chloride anions are the
spectator ions and leaving those out we
get the net ionic equation which is
ammonia nh3 plus h plus goes to nh4 plus
so this is one way to write the net
ionic equation for this weak base strong
acid titration next let's look at the
titration curve for our weak base strong
acid titration ph is on the y-axis and
milliliters of acid is on the x-axis
because we're adding our strong acid to
our aqueous solution of our weak base
looking at the first point on our
titration curve the ph is relatively
basic so this is before any strong acid
has been added the reason why the ph is
basic is because we have an aqueous
solution of our weak base ammonia which
reacts with water to produce ammonium
cations and hydroxide anions and it's
these hydroxide anions that cause the ph
to be relatively high
however the equilibrium favors the
reactants for this reaction so we have
mostly ammonia and very little ammonium
at this point in the titration curve
next we think about adding some acid to
our aqueous solution of ammonia and from
our net ionic equation when ammonia
reacts with h plus that forms the
ammonium cation nh4 plus looking at the
titration curve as we add more and more
acid the ph starts to decrease however
in this range there's a slow decrease in
the ph
as more acid is added more ammonia is
turned into the ammonium cation
eventually we reach a point where all of
the initial ammonia has been neutralized
by the addition of the acid this point
is called the equivalence point
and the way to find the equivalence
point on our titration curve is to first
look for this sharp decrease in the ph
and then we can draw a straight line
here and approximately halfway down that
straight line is a good estimate of the
equivalence point for this titration
to find the ph of the solution at the
equivalence point we simply go over to
where the equivalence point is on the
y-axis and so for this ph we can see the
ph at the equivalence point is less than
seven so let me go ahead and write that
down here the ph is less than seven for
a weak base strong acid titration the
reason why the ph is less than seven at
the equivalence point is because all the
ammonia that we started with has been
completely neutralized and turned into
the ammonium cation nh4 plus the
ammonium cation is a weak acid and
reacts with water to form hydronium ions
h3o plus and ammonia in aqueous solution
at 25 degrees celsius water has a ph of
seven however since the ammonium cation
is weak acid and we're increasing the
concentration of hydronium ions in
solution that decreases the ph therefore
the ph is less than seven at the
equivalence point in addition to
ammonium ions there are also chloride
anions in solution however chloride
anions do not react with water and
therefore do not affect the ph
going back to the equivalence point on
our titration curve if we drop down here
to the x-axis we can see the equivalence
point occurs after 50 milliliters of
acid has been added therefore if it took
50 milliliters of acid to neutralize all
of the ammonia that was initially
present it would take half that volume
or 25 milliliters of acid to neutralize
half of the ammonia so if we go back up
here and we draw a dashed line to our
titration curve this point on our
titration curve represents the half
equivalence point
so this point represents the half
equivalence point on our titration curve
and since we've neutralized half the
half of the ammonia that was initially
present that means there are equal
concentrations of ammonia and the
ammonium cation at this point let's go
back to our equivalence point where all
the ammonia that we started with has
been neutralized therefore if we add
some more acid to the solution there's
no more ammonia for it to react with and
therefore we see the ph drop
so this portion of the titration curve
is the region of excess acid
let's go back to the half equivalence
point on our titration curve remember at
that point the concentration of ammonium
cation is equal to the concentration of
ammonia the ammonium cation and ammonia
are a conjugate acid-base pair and when
there are significant amounts of a weak
conjugate acid-base pair there's a
buffer solution
therefore at the half equivalence point
we have a buffer solution and we can
calculate the ph at that point by using
the henderson henderson-hasselbach
equation so ph is equal to the pka of
the weak acid plus the log of the
concentration of the conjugate base
divided by the concentration of the weak
acid for this example the base is
ammonia nh3 and the conjugate acid is
the ammonium cation nh4 plus therefore
this pka value in the
henderson-hasselbalch equation is
referring to the pka value of ammonium
and because the concentrations of
ammonium and ammonia are equal at the
half equivalence point the ratio of
their concentrations is equal to one and
the log of one is equal to zero
therefore at the half equivalence point
the ph is equal to the pka value of the
weak acid so if we wanted to find the
pka value for the ammonium cation we
would find the half equivalence point
and we'd draw our dotted line over to
where that intersects on our y-axis and
whatever ph that is that's the pka value
of ammonium so in this case it looks to
be a little bit over nine as a good
estimate for the pka value of the
ammonium cation
next let's think about how our titration
curve can tell us about the relative
concentrations of our weak conjugate
acid-base pair we know that at the half
equivalence point where the ph is equal
to the pka value the concentration of
ammonium cations is equal to the
concentration of ammonia so let's think
about a point just to the left of our
half equivalence point which i'm going
to call point p
at point p the ph is greater than the
pka value and we know the initial point
on our titration curve was almost all
weak base almost all nh3 because point p
is in between the initial point where
there was almost all nh3 and the half
equivalence point where there was equal
amounts of nh3 and nh4 plus at point p
there must be more nh3 than nh4 plus
therefore when the ph of the solution is
greater than the pka value we know the
concentration of ammonia is greater than
the concentration of the ammonium cation
or you could say the concentration of
ammonium is less than the concentration
of ammonia we could have also figured
this out using the henderson-hasselbach
equation however it's often easier just
to think about the shape of the
titration curve and where the point in
question is in relation to important
points for example in this case the
initial point and the half equivalence
point
next let's think about a point just to
the right of the half equivalence point
and i'm going to call this point q
at point q
the ph of the solution is less than the
pka point q is in between the half
equivalence point and the equivalence
point which is approximately here on the
titration curve remember at the
equivalence point all the ammonia that
we started with has been converted into
ammonium nh4 plus
and because point q is in between the
half equivalence point where the amount
of nh3 is equal to the amount of nh4
plus and the equivalence point where all
the nh3 has been converted into nh4 plus
all of the initial nh3 that means that
at q there must be more nh4 plus than
nh3 therefore when the ph is less than
the pka value we can say the
concentration of ammonium nh4 plus is
greater than the concentration of
ammonia and h3 the half equivalence
point point p and point q
are all a part of the buffer region on
the titration curve
remember that buffers resist large
changes in ph and that's why we see a
slow decrease in ph as acid is added at
this part of the titration curve at the
very beginning of the titration we had
almost all ammonia and therefore we did
not have a buffer solution however as
acid was added and the ammonia was
converted into the ammonium cation nh4
plus when significant amounts of both
are present we do have a buffer solution
and that represents the buffer region on
our titration curve so in here however
as more and more acid is added we can
see a sharp change in ph start to occur
right about here so we're no longer in
the buffer region as we approach the
equivalence point so when we think about
the titration curve of a weak base
strong acid titration and we think about
the half equivalence point where the ph
is equal to the pka value of the weak
acid it's important to remember that
there's a buffer region or a buffer zone
around that half equivalence point